we need to radically reduce the size
scope and spending of government that
would be a reboot that would help us
become a livelier more responsive
Society
hello and welcome to Marshall matters
with me Winston Marshall for The
Spectator today I have the pleasure of
being joined by Nick Gillespie who is
the editor at large at the libertarian
magazine and website reason.com and is
the author of the book The Declaration
of Independence and a friend
thank you so much for coming to speak
into extremely uh great to be on here I
can I suggest that you change the name
though of the podcast to the Marshall
Plan
[Laughter]
then start becoming more prescriptive
and demanding out of the world to check
yeah but was American that would be the
name yeah
um well I was wondering if we could
start this
a few things I want to discuss I want to
ask about libertarianism and American
libertarianism censorship in America
free speech in America but I wanted to
start if I may with something that I
find
that I haven't fully understood which is
the book Banning
um Obama last week on his Twitter put
out and on his website put out a piece
decrying the book Banning not just of
lgbtq literature he even mentions
conservative literature and is the case
that
books like genderqueer a graphic novel
by Maya Kobe flamer a graphic novel by
Mike barato and this book is gay by Juno
Dawson
these books are sort of seem to be
Progressive literature that is being
banned at the same time
conservative literature if it can be
called conservative literature like for
example Abigail schreier's irreversible
damage about the phenomenon of gender
dysphoria amongst young teenage girls
that's also being banned I wondered if
you could explain what exactly is
happening yeah there has definitely been
increased attention paid to what is in
public libraries and particularly School
libraries K-12 School libraries mostly
Public School libraries over the past
couple of years I mean this is a
definite Battleground in the culture
wars which increasingly are dictating
all the conversation in American
politics like you know I I bet every
reason was established in 1968 I've been
there since 1993 so I've been up on 30
years actually being there and until
maybe a decade ago we used to talk a lot
more in politics about things like the
size of the national debt whether or not
we should be running an annual deficit
what is good versus bad foreign policy
and and you know realistically over the
past five to ten years more and more
topics have been gravitating to this
cultural War type stuff so that that's
you know you know should should gay
people have the same rights to get
married as as straight people Etc that
was one thing you know that got solved
now we're talking about trans issues and
things like that and then it plays out
increasingly in what books do you allow
in a public space right
um how do how do colleges what kinds of
students do they admit or not private or
public but especially you know when
we're talking about public policy it's
really about public uh schools and you
know this the book Banning stuff you
know it's wrong to call these book bands
in the sense that they are not it's not
censorship it's not George Orwell it's
not Ray Bradbury and Fahrenheit 451
where people are going around and you
know burning books or extirpating them
uh interestingly there are increasing
attempts to stop certain books from
being published that overwhelmingly
seems to be coming from the left so when
there are books that you know are deemed
to be be politically incorrect or not
sufficiently woke or you know they
transgress some line uh you know you
will see online campaigns to get
Publishers to drop certain things there
was a book that came out a while ago a
couple years ago called American dirt
and it was a book written by a white
American about a um a Hispanic woman
kind of moving you know illegally
migrating to the United States and that
became a huge flash point the book was
published it was a massive publishing
success so it didn't work and that's
also important to think about but you
know in the broader context of cancel
culture there are you know more and more
visible attempts to shut down certain
types of speech
um you know what's interesting is that I
think in a profound way this reflects
the fact that more people are able to
speak more freely in more places than
ever before so you know the one way of
thinking about it is like we are in this
repressive cycle where people are trying
to shut down speech they disagree with I
think that's true but paradoxically and
probably more important there are more
ways to speak than ever before that ties
in with Martin guri's theory of that big
so much we're the age of so much
information yeah it's
um and and the adventures whether you
know he talks in in the Revolt of the
public which I think is you know one of
the essential guides to the past 15 or
20 years and and probably the next 15 or
20 years he talks a lot about how
Twitter you know underwrote or empowered
the uh the Arab Spring I in a way that
was UN you know unpredictable or
unforeseeable it's kind of ironic now
that Twitter during covid and during
these types of uh kind of battles Co you
know Twitter is a site of censorship
right or or a repressing certain types
of speech but in the end we live in an
age where more people can talk in more
more ways than ever before so I think we
should be careful in just announcing the
idea that we live in an age of
censorship because that's true I mean
people are trying to control speech more
than ever but more speech escapes that
um that's kind of a broad almost anodic
backdrop to what you're talking about
though with you know public uh Public
Library bands and school bands and um
you know there's no question that uh
kind of K-12 education curricula have
always been political
um they're getting more and more
increasingly politicized and now people
are arguing and often in terms that I
think are wrong to say you know like is
it wrong to take a book like genderqueer
which is very sexually explicit like
independent of what kind of sex is going
on it's very sexually explicit and it
seems to me we have to be having a
series of different conversations and
instead of saying you know genderqueer
is challenged in a in and it's in the
adult section or the young adult section
of a public library that's one thing to
say it's it's being removed from a
middle school library and that kind of
makes sense
um because it really is sexually
explicit in a way I don't think most
people would say yeah that's that's good
for fifth graders or third graders
um and then there's that broader context
of like the fact is more and more books
from lgbtq plus authors are being
published and are being read which as a
Libertarian and I like free speech I
like individualism I like people being
able to express themselves but then
we're having these struggles over you
know in what context Etc and we're we're
kind of having the wrong debate in a lot
of ways what do you think the the
correct debate is I think the correct
debate is to be thinking about with
something like K-12 education if the
school curriculum and if the school
library is stocking books or or the
teachers are pushing books and and
curricula you know a curriculum on your
your kids that you don't believe in
you know the policy fixed to that isn't
to say okay everybody who lives in this
school district either gets something
taught you know to them whether the
parents like it or not or they are not
allowed to learn about this it's to
create more school choice so that there
are more ways that parents can match
their kids to the schools that they
blocked and that's also a big movement
right now for public school choice as
well as you know private school choice
that's still pretty complicated moving
your kid because a little bit yeah but
do you think sort of it was like a
federalist system yeah totally I mean
you know and and I say this as somebody
I grew up lower middle class where you
know we're talking in New York I grew up
about 50 miles from here in New Jersey
and I went to very academically shitty
Catholic schools that my parents paid
for and that was a version of school
choice I the the public schools were
much better academically et cetera but
they you know they said they wanted you
know whatever a Catholic Education meant
to them which generally I interpret as
painting like academically less serious
than the public school strangely but you
know if my parents didn't like what the
Catholic school was teaching they could
go to the school and say hey we don't
like this would you do something about
it and then if the Catholic School said
[__] you then they would go to the
public school or another school
um and you know I think that's a better
fit you know we have something like over
a hundred thousand school districts in
America right now
we should have maybe 30 million or
however many K-12 students there are
because everybody should be able to find
an education that your every parent
should be able to find an education that
they think is good for their kid you
mentioned uh Twitter and actually we're
being in an age of abundance of Free
Speech but you and I were both in
Memphis a week or so ago listening to
RFK Jr who's uh part of his presidential
campaign he was censored through covid
uh claims to be the first man to be
censored by the Biden Administration
there seems to be even though it might
be an abundance of free speech or into
social media there's also a lot of
censorship yeah no uh and again censor
you know I don't want to be pedantic
about it but censorship uh or a
squelching of speech I mean like you
know censorship I really think of I
think it's best to keep that as sharply
defined as possible and that is when a
government or a you know a government
that has the force of you know police
says this speech is not allowed and
we're going to go out and strike it down
I'm on the board of a group called ideas
Beyond borders which translates western
words or or various Works about
pluralism and free speech and a lot of
values like that a lot of Enlightenment
values into Arabic and then you know
distributes them for free as ebooks in
the Arab speaking world and you know
there are countries where if you are
caught in possession of a book you are
you are killed or you're put in prison
we're not there and you know that kind
of censorship I don't want to diminish
that flight with you know the fact that
RFK Jr who
um I disagree with a lot I absolutely
agree that his speech was squelched on
Twitter uh and on Facebook and other
social media accounts he was bounced
um you know in in ways that I find
incredibly egregious
um so to you know get to the point it's
this is another Paradox right which is
that Twitter
Twitter facilitates more speech and more
people being able to say whatever they
want and it also definitely was revealed
in the Twitter files reasons Robbie
Suave did a uh he got information about
Facebook that was very similar where
there is no question that Facebook
Twitter other social media platforms
certainly YouTube they were not just
pressured by the government to shut down
certain accounts or to squelch the reach
of certain information because it ran a
foul of some government you know some
government
apparatchiks but that people at these
platforms were going to the government
saying hey what do you think about this
you should we squelch this so there's
something really rotten and second in
all of that and it's good to expose that
and it's good to hold the companies
accountable I'm interested about the the
legal uh side of it because that's
section 213 right which gives them free
from the liability of should a user
right uh slander reliable someone it's
not their responsibility and that would
be insane because it would be they would
have to be a vet every single there
would be no I mean the internet as we
know it would be very very different
there would be no user-generated content
pH is really what has made the internet
what it is by the same token that
section 230 also gives platforms the
right to uh limit speech or to kick
people off and to moderate some speech
without having to moderate all speech
Etc and things like that well uh there's
an argument about whether
Twitter is the Public Square right and
so and so uh I think technically it's it
has to be the government that's uh
stopping free speech and it would be the
case in Twitter files that it was the
government colluding to stop Free Speech
but let's say the government weren't
involved in that and it was just the
social media
um and in fact in this the speech that
RFK gave me uh both watched it Elvis
Presley's car park uh garage
um amongst his um Bentleys and roles and
yeah all these yeah
um uh RK gave the example of the 1972
case where a Vietnam anti-war protester
in a shopping mall they were throttled
by the
um the more uh and then they went to the
Supreme Court now RFK claimed in the
speech we saw that the um Supreme Court
sided with the protesters and that the
more was a published Place well actually
rfk's wrong I look right up yeah um that
the Supreme Court sided with the mall
right and that it was a prime it was
private land so there was it was no uh
it wasn't a public space What where do
you think the the law should be on this
is Twitter the Public Square no uh or
rather it is it should not be a uh it
should not be a public a square that is
regulated in the public interest like
the way that broadcast networks are
broadcast radio
uh still is
um because I think when you cross that
line and you say okay you know what
we're effectively going to nationalize
this and say it's so important and so
ubiquitous that we are going to limit
how you can control what speech is
allowed or disallowed on your platform
uh you know uh Ron DeSantis in Florida
and Greg Abbott in Texas the two
governors in Republican states with
Republican majorities in the legislature
have passed laws doing this to social
media companies of a certain sort saying
you can't disallow this speech you can't
do this because they believe that
conservative voices are being
systematically squelched and those are
being held up in court because they I
you know you I under however bad twitter
was you know before Elon Musk and now I
guess it's X you know he is after Elon
Musk
um it's going to be much much worse if
the government is saying this speech is
allowable and this speech is not that
and that would be a blow to free speech
the other thing that we should think
about is I have a you know and this is
I'm a Libertarian so I believe in you
know that markets are not perfect but
they facilitate a lot of options and we
have seen just in the past couple of
years a you know a raft of alternatives
to something like Twitter right you know
we have threads most recently that is
you know from meta
um which is completely flopped uh well
it's been completely flipped it had a
big you know rush and now people are
less interested in it right
um but you also have Noster and blue sky
and a variety of other uh programs and
platforms and it seems to me you know
Twitter has also changed
um because they have to respond to
criticism and that it's better to work
through kind of Market forces and say
you know to protest to
um you know go to the to the people who
run these platforms and say you know
what this isn't working push for change
within that or create your own and now
having said that
um you know back in the day not very
long ago
you know conservatives did that was a
stock liberal answer when you know
conservatives would say hey we're
getting screwed on Facebook and Twitter
and liberals would say well go build
your own platform then if you don't like
it and you know then conservatives did
that with uh parlor in particular and
then you know various other you know
liberal or Progressive people working at
Amazon web services and another you know
and in app stores kept trying to keep
parlor down so it's not it's not clean
it's not easy but I think that kind of
rough and tumble is far preferable to
giving the government you know the very
government that nobody trusts the
ability to say this speech is okay you
cannot censor this speech you you have
to carry this speech no thanks we did
that throughout all of the 20th century
and mass media you know whether it was
radio TV uh whatever and it was what do
you mean we did that we you know the
government said uh in order to if if you
were a TV station that brought test over
the air or a radio station you were you
had to carry certain speech or you
couldn't not carry things you had to
have things like the fairness Doctrine
you had to have equal time and what that
did was it degraded public discourse so
that only a few viewpoints would be
aired what we live in now and this I
think for me is one of the conceptual
uh kind of Frameworks or the conceptual
breakthroughs we need and I I have been
struggling to articulate this so maybe
it's just like a an ink Kuwait and dung
thought in my mind but it seems to me we
are we're grab we're in a world now
where so many things are possible and so
many things are happening and so many
great things are happening particularly
in terms of mass personalization
individual empowerment autonomy but
we're struggling to kind of understand
them and regulate them through a 20th
century model of kind of top-down you
know pop men you know the best and the
brightest controlling things from the
top everything in the 21st century is
the best parts are about bottom up
emergent orders individuals doing what
they want and we need to come up with
kind of mindsets as well as institutions
and political policy solutions that take
that into account and allow that to kind
of proliferate rather than saying know
you know what we need to do is to
maintain a monopoly you know what
political duopoly between Republicans
and Democrats and speech rights between
liberals and progressor and progressives
and conservatives like we're you know we
look around in the world and it is you
know for the first time in human history
according to Brookings institution and
some U.N uh Charters a majority of
people around the world live in middle
class circumstances this is unbelievable
we never talk about that we don't talk
about the implications of that uh we you
know we live in a world where you can
self-publish anything you want and you
have a chance of getting an audience for
it and we are talking about you know
we've got to keep genderqueer or To Kill
a Mockingbird or Huff Finn out of eighth
grade English you know it's like what
the [__] we are we're we're like um Dr
Faustus in um and Christopher Marla's
fastest where it's like suddenly you
know we we have the ability to do
anything we want we have this in
incredible demonic power in the best way
possible and we're doing things like
pinching girls asses and laying sausages
on the nose of the Pope we we we're like
we're locked in a struggle a Twilight
Struggle for the 20th century which
we've left behind uh we we should just
be doing we should be doing better with
all that is available to us something's
happening both my country your country
and if I can just go back one step to
the social media
issue is in my country it's coming
through the Online safety bill yeah and
here uh 200 student school districts
have joined to litigation against big
tech companies to child proof the
internet this seems to be one of the
fault lines on on uh free speech what
yeah
what's the significance of this how how
much am I allowed to curse on this
podcast
away I don't know but I you know school
districts will do everything to blame
everybody except themselves like the
idea that the reason why school kids
aren't learning is because of tick tock
or Instagram or Facebook is so [__]
embarrassing I mean you know in New York
State uh the average uh K-12 uh cost per
pupil is something like 30 grand and
they can't teach kids to read that isn't
because of social media it's something
that is happening in the schools and
again I think better school choice you
would be matching kids with schools that
they're actually interested or that that
know how to teach to that particular kid
et cetera I think you know I I think you
would see a lot of these social problems
disappear because they're not really
problems it's just like you know if you
were uh if if you were an intellectual
kid and you got sent to a football
school and like you're not going to do
well and like we need to sort people
better and everything will will get
better but the idea that
um you know school districts are going
to try and shut down or regulate or
extract attacks out of tick tock and
Facebook and Twitter and Instagram
you've got to be kidding me like that is
such an invasion of basic responsibility
and and if I may like this is where you
know you get past the right left thing
because conservatives and progressives
both hate social media right for
different reasons
um but they're you know they're full of
it I mean it's like it isn't it isn't
those things that are failing our
children when they spend you know six to
eight hours a day nine months out of the
year in a public school it's what's
happening in the schools I think well uh
so as you say social media is getting
blamed for everything and I I just had
dinner with uh men mentioned earlier
yeah author and I've talked to her a
couple of times her next book is about
the uh I'm not sure this is her term but
it seems to me the therapy industrial
complex and how American children are
being ushered through therapy and
everything yeah
over uh prescribed medicines until they
have various conditions there's many
other issues affecting Americans and I
wonder what you think those other ones
are which ones we should be really more
concerned with uh you know I
um
I think that fundamentally what we are
doing is we are in a
um we're in a fight between different
what are called declension narratives
um so that the dominant discourse in
America and I suspect this is somewhat
true in England or in the UK and it is
in most of Europe as well which is that
we live in a period
after the Golden Age and you know
depending on who you are you'll pick
this was the golden age or that was the
golden age but we talk about everything
as a crisis that needs to be addressed
immediately and I alone have the one
solution you know and this is RFK Jr has
a hard on about vaccines you know and
it's covered vaccines now before that it
was MMR but that's why everything is
screwed up right and um you know Abigail
schreier will have a different thing and
it's about gender ideology and you know
and that's destroying every you know
other people will say it's uh you know
it's Instagram and it is forcing you
know it's making people want things that
they will never be able to afford you
know whatever it is like there's all
sorts of things uh you know people will
say it's late capitalism you know and
this is you know we're just grinding to
the end of anyways yeah yeah you know
and
um the first and foremost thing that we
should be doing is kind of reevaluating
these declension narratives uh because
in fact when you look in America if you
look at things like after taxes and
transfer payments the number of children
who are living in poverty is at an
all-time low the number of single women
with children or households with
children at all-time lows
um you know the the amount of men in
America yeah and in America but then
again around the world things are going
fantastically well you know 25 years ago
when the UN started talking about we
want to you know help knock down the the
absolute poverty right uh in around the
world we hit those milestones and blew
through them much quicker than anybody
thought you know fewer people die of
weather-related disasters around the
world at any point in history in
absolute terms even though we have many
more people in the globe much less you
know in percentages and things like that
there are so many things that are going
well women are doing fantastically well
in contemporary America by most material
yardsticks things like graduating from
college Medical School law school and
yet what do we you know what do we hear
about it's like that everything is
Darkness well uh forgive me for then not
following you no it's positive yeah
because I don't want to keep sticks
I was just going to say that
Libertarians are usually apocalyptic
they're like you know if you raise this
tax one quarter of one percent
civilization is fragile and it'll
disappear but it's like we're actually
in the middle of a hell of a run
including after covid you know within a
couple months when when kofit started
and then people were talking about okay
we got to get vaccines for this stuff
they were saying it's going to take
three to five years to get vaccines you
know prepped and ready and out into the
world and it took eight months and it
could have been shorter if we changed
the way that we actually go through the
approval process of drugs and I realize
you know there are there are there are
issues about the way that we dealt with
covid the public health authorities lied
about stuff consistently we should have
been more attuned to the how covet
affected different people of different
ages and we punished you know young
children and we punish young adults
particularly men uh you know we're
getting forcing I'm against vaccine
mandates under almost all circumstances
and under the coveted uh you know regime
but you know we had this worldwide
pandemic which we essentially figured
out how to end it in a record period of
time far more up you know better than
the most optimistic forecasts and we are
still like you know what this world is
horrible it's terrible it's like no
we're we're like doing quite well as a
as a planet and as a as a society and as
a civilization well having just read
rfk's book on Tony fauci I could go into
the my criticisms of the of the vaccine
but yeah no and fauci you know for for
reason is that sometimes parallel but
are distinct from what Kennedy does now
fauci has a so much to answer for we
just did a reason a hour and a half long
conversation with Matt Ridley the great
science writer who also co-authored this
is one because you've been speaking to
Matt Ridley yeah he's a rational
Optimist and also very tall like but you
know what he's British it's like
everything's coming up roses with Matt
Ridley but
um you know we it was a critique of the
way the public health authorities acted
during covet and also the way they
worked was the government and Twitter
and Facebook and other social medias to
squelch the lab leak theory for reasons
that are deeply deeply disturbing
um and absolutely everybody should be
livid at this but so there's a lot of
reasons to be
um you know angry and and truly critical
of Anthony Foundry there's also that
large point that we you know we are done
with this pandemic and the next one is
likely not to be as bad because we know
we made certain advances with M nrna
vaccines and again we could get into a
conversation about that but
you know this is like we did pretty well
I wanted to ask you about
um a a poll that you published at reason
I think it was a Newsweek one yes about
uh the rise in popularity of making
misgendering a crime for four percent of
Millennials want to make misgendering a
crime right in America 38 of 35 to 44
year olds said it should be a crime and
this seems to match up with what I've
witnessed in the creative Industries in
GL aad gay and lesbian alliance against
defamation posted an open letter signed
by hundreds of uh artists and
celebrities alike including people like
John Avatar
Jamil and um many others looking for the
censorship of misgendering dead naming
people censorship of misinformation
about uh healthcare for Gen for Trans
kids in line with covid censorship it
seems that
censorship is popular and
I that's particularly startling in this
country with the first amendment I I
wondered what your why you think that
this is the case of the younger
Generations have taken this turn or
where they don't necessarily value Free
Speech or why uh let's say even I'm not
sure it's hate speech necessarily to
misgender someone it might be an
accident but it seems like it's being
roped into the idea that it is hate
speech and hate speech should be
actionable and things like that I mean
yes where again to go back to the
starting point I think of this
conversation there's definitely a spasm
of you know censorship or sensoriousness
sensorialness
um you know that is that is alive and
and kind of growing right um which is
deeply deeply disturbing I think uh you
know so I'm turning 60 in a couple weeks
I'm at the end of the baby boom and I
grew up in a moment like I grew up in
the 70s and 80s really and that I you
know I took for granted that Free Speech
even objectionable speech was you know
that was the the ante of living in a
free society and a good Society is that
you would put up with bad speech and you
would counter it with better speech
right this is like the ACLU used to talk
about this all the time uh and the ACLU
is now on the side of censoring things
right or you know I don't know that they
want to criminalize misgendering people
but they're you know they've abdicated
their open Speed uh you know kind of
positions
PLC yeah yeah absolutely and and you
know that is deeply deeply disturbing
and I think one of the you know to ask
why are millennials or you know younger
people who were raised by Baby Boomers
who supposedly care about free speech I
mean this is an interesting kind of
conundrum and I think that a lot of
Boomers have given up on Free Speech
because they feel like oh things are too
important now
um and they taught their children I have
you know I have a two kids one is a
millennial and one is Gen X
um I didn't teach them this but they got
from a lot of different places that you
know speech is the equivalent of action
or you know and and that words wounds
you know like bullets or knife knife
blades or something like that
um and this is what happens when you
teach that there's an equation between
speech and action
um you know then you have to police
speech because it's the same thing it's
like
who's been teaching this I haven't seen
speech in action I think that is a
coursing through K-12 education I think
through a lot of um you know media and
and creative work and things like that
um I think and I wrote about this in 98
or 99 of us you know you mentioned child
proofing the world I wrote a cover story
for a reason called child proofing the
world and it was in the late 90s chill
children bite every possible measure
we're doing better than ever and there
was a concerted effort mostly coming
from liberal and Progressive forces like
Hillary Clinton was a leader in this to
child proof the world because they were
saying that kids were at higher and
higher risks for all sorts of uh
problems including you know encountering
violent uh video games or violent music
you know this was any era when the
parents music Resource Center was saying
you know listening to Darling Nikki by
Prince or she bought by Cyndi Lauper
insanely you know would somehow ruin
children forever that world view has uh
you know just dominated and dominated I
I chucked it up to a number of of things
including the fact that we were having
fewer children so each child took on
relative more weight we were spending
more raising kids as a society
um so like literally we were putting
fewer eggs in in a basket and projecting
all of her hopes and our anxieties on
them and we wanted to protect them it's
like the story of the Buddha you know
the Buddha's parents the Buddha's father
that wants to keep him in a Walled
Garden where he never sees illness or
poverty or death or old age we've been
doing that as a society for the past 30
years at least have become more precious
about our children and it's all proceeds
from this absolutely Miss begotten
premise that children are not resilient
um you know or or and that Society is
not resilient and I think it's now taken
on a logic of its own I think
compounding that the kids who were
raised under that who are the ones who
are you know 25 to 34 or 25 to 44 are
moving into power now there's a
generational Dynamic to this the baby
boom you know which was between 46 and
64 was such a massive generation and it
just it kicked out you know as it was
moving into you know its 30s and 40s it
dethroned the greatest Generation in the
silent generation the people you know
who follow World War II and you know
where before who came of age before the
60s and you used you generational shifts
like this you use whatever is around to
get rid of the Old Guard
um we are going through something
similar like that the millennial
generation is a massive cohort and
especially when you combine it with Gen
Z baby boomers are sticking around
longer they're clogging up together at
the top of the Masthead they're at the
top of the you know Corporation they're
still dominating a lot of cultural
production I mean that's starting to
shift but I think part of what you're
seeing now from this you know group The
you know let's say Millennials you know
people in their early 40s to late 20s
you're seeing uh cons
not a coordinated effort but a concerted
effort to get to dislodge the baby boom
generation and one of the ways to do
that me too was part of that and speech
police is part of that because like who
is who who is most stricken now you know
it's like covet was the Boomer remover
right like it mostly killed old people
um so did these efforts I think a lot of
them are aimed at pushing out older
people so you have people who are raised
to believe words or violence and that
you know you need to police everything
because otherwise you're gonna hurt
people and cause trauma which has been
expanded in its definition to include
basically everyday life
um you have that and then you have the
need you know to get rid of the people
who are who are clogging up the works if
the bus break decline is continuing what
is the way out of this preciousness or
maybe a broader question is
how do we show the value of free speech
how does this turn around yeah that's uh
those are great questions one I mean
embedded in the idea that declining
birth rates or fertility rates is a
problem is a sense that
um you know if if there are fewer people
on the planet you know economic and kind
of social progress stops and there you
know there's a lot of theorists who
believe that
um include you know both Libertarians
conservatives liberals and progressives
mostly agree that on some level like if
you have a shrinking population it's
hard to maintain economic and material
progress and it's interesting given that
you know the early end of the baby boom
uh in the late 60s and early 70s was
fixated on overpopulation there were too
many people it's drawing Mother Earth we
needed to really depopulate and now of
course now that we have that you know
it's it's not here yet but it's in the
you know it's on the horizon how people
are freaking out yeah oh we're not going
to have enough people
um I think uh there's a couple things
one is that like fertility declines
again or one of these things where uh
well a year ago or so
um the there were tons of news reports
because there was a Census Bureau that
women were having fewer babies like
Millennial women were having fewer
babies than ever oh what a freak out but
it's like actually what that reflects is
the fact that women have more
opportunities and options and that both
men and women want smaller families
because they you know they're doing more
they're lit we're living longer we're
doing more things it's actually the
decline in fertility is the result I
would argue
um of modernity when it of giving people
more options and more control over their
biology I don't see that in and of
itself as a problem that needs to be
corrected because it's also a global
phenomenon everywhere people are having
fewer kids and the reason for that is
because they have more individual
control over their reproduction
ensure that there's an actual desire for
fewer kids or let's say in in the west
could it not be that there's you know
for example in in Britain the housing we
have a housing crisis very expensive
because this is the same thing across
Europe it's that actually families can't
afford or it's a it's a big Financial
bigger than ever Financial hit there's
uh there's a demographer or a social
scientists at the American Enterprise
Institute name Scott Winship who has
looked at this and he looked at the the
number he he uh looked at data that
asked you know Boomer women in the late
or not Boomer women but uh women in the
late 50s and early 60s how many kids did
you want to have and then how many kids
did they have to see like how close did
they get to their go you know their
dream of when they're in their you know
20s
um and then he did the same thing with
early Millennials and Millennials wanted
fewer kids and but they're closer to
their aspirational goal than Boomer
women were and
um I think what has happened and this is
something you know again I mentioned I
grew up uh you know of a boomer and I
went to Catholic school when I was in uh
grammar school and high school like
there were always a couple of families
in every grade that had you know eight
or twelve kids I mean it was a very
cartoon Catholic thing right
um those families don't exist anymore
and I don't think that's primarily
because uh you know college costs a lot
or housing has gone up it's also true
like housing when you get outside of a
few Market areas is not as you know
housing has gone up a lot in New York it
hasn't you know if you're in a small
town in Ohio or something it's not you
know it's it's still affordable but I
think women uh this is something that
John Amazon last who is a conservative
writer who is at the Weekly Standard and
is now at the dispatch I believe
um wrote a book about it called what to
expect when nobody's expecting and he
concluded you know across the globe
everybody agrees that the more years of
education women have the fewer children
they have so I think it's right to say
that and he actually says you know that
to change that is you would have to
repeal modernity where women have more
control and autonomy over their bodies
where they have more options where they
have more rights and equal status in
society I think yeah so
um I you know I I don't think that the
push for fewer children is either
because things are more expensive or
because you know the other thing that
you hear a lot particularly on the left
is I don't want to bring a child into a
world that is about to burn to death or
say you know you know the planet is
about to become a cinder I think it
reflects a lot a lot of changes that are
Global and that are not going to change
anytime soon a very human civilization
is a movement towards fewer kids per
family
and which um so which is a move by the
way towards the end of the human race
maybe maybe not it's you know because
you can we're also much more efficient
and productive I think it will represent
or it will produce certain kinds of
challenges you see this uh Japan is the
one developed economy that has fewer
people now than it had in 2000.
um it is an intensely closed society
when it comes to reproduction and many
other things including female status
it's a very dysfunctional society and
they are going to have to change if they
want to maintain a standard of living
and it's not just regarding gender but
you know they have since uh really the
early 1990s they have gone into an
economic slide a kind of sideways
movement that they won't be able to
maintain forever but because they won't
allow markets to function and flush out
poorly performing companies because they
are a mix of hyper you know kind of
creative destruction in markets and
traditional structures and that's not
going to work forever I think America is
becoming a little bit ossified like that
I think parts of Europe have and this
again is like we we need to leave the
20th century behind and instead of
starting to say you know what we need to
get back to that moment after World War
II where for the first time in recorded
history birth rates started going up for
a little bit you know the baby boom in
the US anyway and we have to be this is
the reality how do we how do we maximize
happiness how do we uh create individual
rights how do we create meaning in the
world and given where we are now now not
where we were in 1970 or 1950. so your
other question was how do we reverse
this question about free speech and I
think you know for me free speech is
important because individual expression
is you know the thing that I value the
most probably and I don't mean that just
in speech I mean that like you know you
should be able to live your life the way
that you want to I should be able to do
that I should be able to run my business
the way that I want to you know Etc
um I think that's a better world it's a
more interesting World a more productive
World a more prosperous World ultimately
a more fair world and this is the
libertarian yeah very much so I think
and you know that's a really good
question like how do we start to build a
culture of free speech and a free
expression and of not Anarchy not
everyone for themselves but a kind of
laissez-faire that then also has a
communal aspect to it and builds you
know has a respect for the need of a
social safety net and to make sure that
everybody is enfranchised in a society
what is the social safety net mean for a
Libertarian Life For Me Yeah I know you
know and I speak for myself here a lot
of Libertarians call themselves or you
know or actually they'll say they're a
narco-capitalist so they don't believe
that there should be any government or
that there needs to be any government
that things will work out otherwise I'm
not there I'm more of a classical
liberal coming out of uh 18th and 19th
century kind of revolutions and uh both
in industry but also mostly in political
philosophy where I believe in a limited
government
um and I think you know the one of the
ways that we do that we have a
government in America that since 2000
um you know has quintupled or quadruple
or let me we've gone from tripled we
went from uh annual budgets in the
federal government of about two trillion
dollars to over 6 trillion and it looks
like we're not coming back
the government is doing too many things
it's spending too much and it does very
few of them well we need a government
that is smaller but more effective in
the things that it provides and I think
you know there's like National Defense
we could easily cut the defense budget
in half and America wouldn't be any less
safe I don't think our interests around
the world would be less safe we just
spent 20 years you know
Prosecuting two disastrous Wars you know
in Afghanistan it it's Darkly laughable
that you know we went in there to pose
the Taliban built a bunch of [__] left
things behind and then to the Taliban
it's like here you go for right you know
it's like that wasn't good I don't think
we did you know the Middle East is doing
better now that we have left
um you know and this is partly Donald
Trump and the Abraham Accord set things
up in motion where the you know the
Middle East the people in the Middle
East are starting to do what they need
to be you know what they need to in
order to have a better place but we
could reduce the size of defense
spending we could reduce the amount of
social welfare spending so that you know
most transfer payments you know where
tax dollars go to a favored group those
aren't going to poor people they're not
going to people who need food clothing
and shelter they're around to middle
class people you know to subsidize
student loans to subsidize Health Care
to subsidize mortgage interest payments
like we need to radically reduce the
size scope and spending of government
and have it be effective and efficient
on the people it's helping
um and that is the beginning that would
be a reboot that I think would help us
become a livelier more responsive
Society yeah you know you just uh
progressives conservatives to Democrats
from Republicans alike by the state of
the world you've just described how big
the government expenditure is yeah and
yet he calls off the optimistic
theatarian yeah yeah where is where's
your optimism drive from uh yeah you
know it's because this uh and you know
the last few years have certainly been
taxing to this optimism and possibly to
the do you know the veracity of this
statement I've always believed that
um we generally
um you know technology is the kind of
handmaiden or the engine of a lot of
freedom
um you know once you uh once you have
you know better technology people can
live more on their own or you know we
have more developed markets so like I
don't have to churn my own butter and
make my own clothes Etc and a lot of
that is the you know it's both policy
and political Theory but it's also just
technology
um and I think that what we have seen
over the past couple of hundred years at
least is that the technology that allows
us to live more freely outpaces the the
growth of the government to kind of hem
it all in and I think that's part of my
optimism I mean government is growing
um you know but there is a surplus of
kind of autonomy that comes from these
things as well as the breakdown in
Social mores and things like that and
again I realize for conservatives and
traditionalists and they can be right or
for let's say traditionalists and they
can be right-wing or left-wing the
breakdown of things like uh you know the
church you know where you know whatever
Church you believe in but in religiosity
um the breakdown in the belief that
there are there's a mandarin class that
knows best whether we're talking about
what is the best art what is the best
culture in literature or what is the
best way to live those are breaking down
um and that frees up individualism I'm
more able to live my life the way that I
want to that my parents were or my
grandparents were I think my children
will have even more ability to do that
despite the growth of government but
that doesn't mean we should allow
government to just keep growing and kind
of be a barnacle on the whole of you
know the great ship Freedom or something
like that I think things would be much
better and most importantly you know I'm
uh you know I'm like upper class I think
you know on a strict income level and
things like that I can take care of
myself if we reduce the size scope and
spending of government and targeted on
people who needed it I think we would be
enabling and empowering those people to
live Fuller richer lives you don't sound
like clitarian to me you sound like a
liberal yeah in English in an English
yes but maybe that's my uh this yeah you
know I don't I don't take that as an
insult or anything
well it's interesting because the
libertarian movement you know over uh
which really you know doesn't start in
its current form until at least after
World War II and maybe even like in the
late 60s and early 70s
um you know that has been drifting more
and more towards anarchism which I think
is is different so like I don't
you know I'm not a foundationalist where
I you know everything we've got to go
back to you know year zero and rebuild
the world Anew according to the right
principles I'm an incrementalist or
sometimes I call myself a directional
libertarian where it's like if we are
moving in the direction of more
individual freedom and autonomy you know
let's do that and let's get there a
little bit faster because uh some of the
things you you've described for example
reducing expenditure on on uh American
Military you know the military
industrial complex sort of makes would I
would imagine that a character like RFK
is would be your side he's saying that
um most vocally of all the candidates of
the of the major candidates uh Vivek
ramaswamy might be saying something
similar it gets confusing uh you know
the thing is when I talk to RFK uh
junior you know it's also you know on
other levels like I asked him you know
it's it's not clear that he would cut
overall government spending so he
believes you know that the
military-industrial complex is real he
believes the Deep State you know
particularly the CIA killed both his
father improperably to be honest and his
uncle JFK more probable but I also think
wrong
um so you know he he is not libertarian
in the sense that he doesn't he doesn't
Envision a world in which the government
is doing fewer things and less things
but on certain issues we kind of line up
in terms of the immediate you know
policy prescription do you is that do
you think and maybe time back to earlier
in the conversation about social media
do you think that there's a time for
some of the antitrust that we saw let's
say with the Sherman Act in 1890 big
farmer we've talked about big Tech is is
it time uh for to break up these big
monopolies is that is that part of the
problem yeah I don't think so and this
might be the dogmatic libertarian in me
um I'm very taken by the analysis of a
lot of antitrust law that um both some
socialist historians as well as
libertarian kind of public Choice
economists are called where uh they
reverse the script and say uh you know
the big story that gets told by
progressives in America is that you know
in the coming into the 20th century the
robber barons you know controlled
everything and then a band of Plucky you
know invigorated liberal or non-liberal
but progressive reformers came in and
said you know know what we're not going
to let the railroad run roughshod over
individual people Etc and there was a
socialist historian called Gabriel culco
who showed that actually you know when
it came to the railroad regulation the
railroads were the ones calling forward
and betting it all along because they're
profits at certain flattening are
declining and they went to the
government you know at at the Satan
Federal level and they were like you
know what it's time to regulate us and
they did that in a way where it fixed
the market for you know uh until the
Carter Administration essentially where
it created a bunch of federal
commissions and that's something
different though that's crony capitalism
no no but this this is when you talk
about social media in 2018 Congress you
know finally got around to say you know
what social media is bad Facebook
Twitter Amazon you know all of you
people come here and talk to us because
you have Monopoly power and what
happened Mark Zuckerberg and uh Tim Cook
of apple and other people were like hey
you know you're right the tech sector
should be regulated and you know what
we're the ones who know the business
Mark Zuckerberg's actually literally
said this to Congress
I will help you write the regulation so
that Facebook is fair it means you know
like there's not going to be any more
Facebooks because once you regulate a
market you fix it but like are you okay
with that and the adults in Congress and
I mean this is important to recognize
they were you know 800 year old mummies
holding up cell phones saying can you
help me reuse this app better
um so I don't think antitrust in almost
no real case when you look at it is it
helping the consumer it is always
somehow serving special interests most
typically corporate interests to fix the
market in the name of helping the public
so and I think that's true of the of the
push to you know break up social media
companies that what what have we seen in
the past year and a half Facebook
changed its name to meta it went into
the metaverse it's it it's losing money
or you know it's losing power and market
share it doesn't matter in the way that
it did even two years ago and it's going
to continue to decline because threads
good bid probably not going to unseat
anything Twitter there are massive
alternatives to Twitter and you know
it's there there are robust markets in
these things so this isn't really an
argument uh against Monopoly as much as
against what actually happens when
regulation comes in and I I we thought
that Libertarians wouldn't have a
problem with Monopoly it would be a more
classical liberal position to be against
Monopoly like a free market or do you
think it actually is a free market it
depends uh when you look at the actual
market so you know this is also uh one
of the major you know cases of this was
Standard Oil
um you know run by John D Rockefeller
and had its moment of peak Market
penetration when it had more the
greatest market share it was charging
the last the least amount for home
heating oil its main product and and
lighting Fuel and stuff like that
because markets that are uh monopolies
that are in markets the way they
maintain their their position is
generally by giving people people more
stuff at lower prices
and I think you know this was true of
AOL uh in the early late 90s and early
2000s when people were saying it's a
monopoly because it dominated the ISP
market and it was giving people more
free stuff than ever and then it
imploded this is something Jonathan
teppa obviously against in a book called
The Myth of capitalism is that actually
there is evidence that those big
monopolies are fixing prices and
monopson just fixing fixing prices which
is hurting the consumer just as much so
it isn't clear to me that uh that it's
it's so obvious that Monopoly is a good
thing yeah and I'm not saying Monopoly
is a good thing the functioning markets
are a good thing so those are slightly
different but even something like Amazon
you know jet came along and is you know
there are certain industries that are
Etsy I mean like if you define you know
it whenever you get into antitrust
action you have to define the relevant
Market and then it's like what is the
market that Amazon is monopolizing and
then do people have more or you know do
they have more or fewer options to get
the things that they're getting through
Amazon and I think you know we're doing
we're doing pretty well as a consumer
society and I know a lot of people who
sell things on Amazon and they hate
working with Amazon Amazon is like
Walmart you know a generation earlier
where it's like it's very punishing to
be a producer you know a vendor for
these companies because they really
squeeze you for every penny in order to
offer generally lower prices to a wider
variety of people but again my general
analysis of Monopoly and things like
that is like is the consumer better or
worse off we can argue in certain ways
you know would there be
would it be better if Facebook was
forced to carry all speech equally and
couldn't prioritize things or not
um I don't know you know and but we're
never going to live in that world
because the minute you say that then
well what about hate speech and then who
gets to Define hate speech Etc and like
then we get mired in all of this you
know this this web of Regulation and
committee and bureaucracy over what is
available what is allowable and all of
that I think it's generally better
um to let markets kind of sort that out
um
Nick on that note I'm going to say thank
you very much for speaking with me uh
fascinating and uh maybe uh you can tell
listeners and Watchers where they can
find you yeah uh reason.com is the
website for a reason everything shows up
there eventually and we have a video
platform we have a bunch of podcasts and
articles plus the magazine goes up there
so reason.com is great and I'm probably
most visible sadly at Twitter or
whatever we're calling it now and my
handle is at Nick palaspio lowercase all
one word thank you so much it's really a
pleasure and an honor
[Music]
thank you